et là vous êtes extraordinaire c'est que
vous adaptez deux enfants trisomiques
je crois que c'était pour me réparer moi
c'était pas c'est presque de l'égoïsme
je voulais des enfants différents parce
que j'avais toujours été différente des
autres
il nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir France Guérin bonsoir
madame bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous avez pas de problème avec les
voisins
vous êtes né le 27 avril
1953 dans le 20e arrondissement de Paris
votre père était tripier voile et votre
mère n'est pas connu elle vous a
abandonné quand vous aviez 9 mois tout à
fait alors jusqu'à l'âge de 5 ans donc
vous vivez chez une nourrice oui et vous
pensiez qu'il s'agissait de votre mère
en fait ma maman Rousseau je l'appelais
et puis un jour votre père vous dit
qu'il a trouvé une nouvelle maman pour
vous et en fait c'est une terrible
maratre pendant des années ça va être
des brimades des punitions des coûts et
vous dites si je suis sourde d'une
oreille c'est à cause de ces caresses
voilà tout à fait
alors cette nouvelle maman vous enferme
régulièrement dans le placard à balais
et là dans l'enfer de la maltraitance
votre colère contenu se transforme en
énergie bienveillante
vous êtes arrivé à
résilier tout à fait faire le contraire
de ce qu'on a fait
dans le placard en train de jouer avec
la serpillière
et vous vous répétez quand je serai une
grande dame j'aurai plein d'enfants je
leur ferai ce qu'on m'a pas fait et je
leur ferai pas ce qu'on m'a fait tout à
fait encore maintenant et j'ai toujours
eu cette devise envers mes enfants voilà
alors vous avez 16 ans quand votre
belle-mère vous met à la porte elle
était ni belle ni ma mère voilà
alors vous balader avenue de Wagram et
vous tombez sur une annonce dans la
vitrine d'une boulangerie
recherchons d'urgence une vendeuse
nourrie logée
vous y allez et on vous prend au kilo
voilà et là vous êtes logé au-dessus de
la boulangerie dans une petite chambre
vous dites le premier weekend vous avez
passé tout le week-end à vous demander
ce qui vous arrivez tellement vous étiez
heureux quoi voilà d'être libre d'être
de faire de pouvoir faire ce que je
voulais voilà d'être indépendant voilà
exactement mais quelques mois après
votre embauche dans cette boulangerie
une méningite vous plonge dans le coma
pendant deux semaines et au réveil vous
êtes hémiplégique tout à fait
un an de rééducation vous finissez par
remarcher et là vous avez découvert le
monde médical parce que on s'était
jamais occupé de moi et tout le temps
que j'ai été à l'hôpital et en
rééducation ben on s'occupait de moi on
soignait on me soignait et pour moi
j'étais heureuse et ça ça me donne envie
de devenir infirmière tout à fait à 19
ans vous faites un enfant avec un beau
jeune homme un beau pompier
[Rires]
qui repart aussitôt oui mais bon il
savait pas que j'étais enceinte et voilà
donc
cet enfant voulait lever en faisant des
petits boulots
et en cachette parce que j'ai été pas
majeur à l'époque c'était 21 ans et
comme j'étais j'avais fait un séjour à
la date j'avais peur qu'on prenne mon
bébé quand vous avez 21 ans vous entrez
comme femme de ménage à l'hôpital et
puis petit à petit vous y croyez pas
mais vous finissez par être infirmière
en faisant les études et avec mon bébé
bien sûr et puis bon voilà vous donner
une infirmière vous faites deux enfants
deux filles mais vous ne laissez pas le
père entrez dans votre vie non je
voulais pas donner un beau-père à ma
fille aînée parce que pour moi beau-père
belle-mère ça voulait dire l'horreur
alors à 33 ans vous rencontrez un homme
avec qui vous décidez de vous marier
et comme vous ne pouvez plus avoir
d'enfant à ce moment-là vous décidez
d'adopter et là vous êtes extraordinaire
c'est que vous adoptez deux enfants
trisomiques non mais il faut pas dire ça
parce que je crois que c'était pour me
réparer moi c'était pas c'est presque de
l'égoïsme je voulais des enfants
différents parce que j'avais toujours
été différente des autres et pour moi
c'était réparé un petit peu tout ça tout
va bien jusqu'au jour de 2004 où vous
perdez votre mari c'est la vie
vos trois filles ont quitté le foyer et
vous restez avec les deux garçons
trisomiques et c'est là qu'un ami vous
parle des Restos du coeur et vous
devenez bénévole au resto du coeur
ce que j'avais été obligé d'arrêter de
travailler parce que mes enfants sont
différents donc l'école différente et
ainsi de suite au début vous faites des
remplacements la nuit mais voilà c'est
très difficile avec les enfants dans la
journée oui et donc c'était où les
mettre en foyer et ça non j'ai pas
adopté des enfants pour les mettre en
foyer ou arrêter de travailler donc j'ai
arrêté de travailler voilà voilà vous
devenez bénévole au resto du coeur et
vous découvrez les Restos du coeur si
vous découvrez qu'il y a beaucoup de
femmes enceintes vous découvrez qui a
énormément de personnes âgées et surtout
la honte et on travaillait tous leur vie
ils ont surtout les personnes âgées et
puis les mamans qui enfin les femmes
âgées qui n'ont jamais travaillé parce
qu'elles ont élevé leur enfant et c'est
un travail croyez-moi mais elles ont pas
de retraite ils ont pas tout ça
tu connais les montants des pensions de
la version on comprend que tu es obligé
de rester du coeur par mois
et puis en 2008 vous commencez à vous
apercevoir que vos fins de mois à vous
aussi deviennent de plus en plus
compliqué la vie est devenue beaucoup
plus cher
et vous avez donc à l'époque 726 euros
par mois pour moi aussi c'était quelque
part la honte de montrer à mes collègues
à tout que j'allais besoin vous n'aviez
jamais eu honte de vivre chichement mais
là aller chercher à manger au resto du
coeur pour moi c'est quelque chose la
peur que on dise que je pouvais plus
élever mes enfants
comme les enlève alors là
je me casse avec eux il y a pas de
problème pas de vous aviez honte de
passer le cap vous n'aviez pas le choix
en vérité
j'ai assez pour faire manger mes enfants
payer le loyer enfin voilà mais j'ai pas
assez pour les emmener en vacances pour
les loisirs et même si mes loulous sont
différents pour moi c'est important qui
connaissent le cinéma il vous
connaissent
qui connaissent le musée même si quelque
part je me dis ils comprennent peut-être
pas ce que je leur raconte ça passe
peut-être au-dessus d'eux parce que ben
ils sont comme ils sont mais pour moi
c'est très important que je fasse avec
mes garçons ce que j'ai pu faire avec
mes filles enfin moi voilà moi j'ai un
tout petit budget en début de mois quand
les allocations familiales arrivent je
divise j'enlève tout ce que je dois
payer l'électricité le téléphone enfin
voilà
quand grâce au resto j'ai pas fait de
courses dû acheter de viande ou d'un
tout ce qui me reste le samedi soir je
le mets dans une tirelire il attire lire
c'est en ce moment la tirelire et pour
le cirque du mois de décembre et voilà
et c'est comme ça que j'arrive à emmener
mes enfants en vacances vous êtes en
train de faire un ours en plus avec une
vieille veste c'est vrai
qui vous a dit ça je sais tout non c'est
vrai c'est vrai
alors Safia comme vous étiez jeune à
Clermont-Ferrand vous aussi avec votre
famille vous avez bénéficier des Restos
du coeur tout le quartier même
les restos du cœur quand Coluche il est
mort on a pleuré mais c'était
elle a complètement raison et moi
inconsciemment peut-être je suis en
charge de la culture à la région
Île-de-France et du cinéma et c'est ça
qui nous manquait parce qu'on arrivait à
avoir les vêtements par Emmaüs
se nourrir avec les Restos du Coeur et
ce qui manque c'est la culture et la
culture c'est l'ouverture sur le monde
moi les Restos du Coeur ça a été mais
vraiment un soutien énorme moi je me
souviens d'une histoire c'est que la
honte c'était assez steak congelé je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte mais
j'ai grandi en Auvergne il y avait il y
a la nature etc et qu'on se retrouve
dans le congélateur à manger ses petits
pavés de steak congelés et ça m'avait
marquer enfant parce que j'avais connu
quand même la bonne viande et on est
passé de la viande à au steak congelé et
ça m'a marqué en fond alors voilà la 28e
campagne des Restos du cœur et commencer
faut quand même dire qu'on est passé de
8 millions et demi de repas en 85 à 115
millions aujourd'hui
toujours en 2011 41% venez pour la
première fois voilà cette année aussi on
en a qui viennent pour la première fois
vous me faites penser un personnage de
films
parce que vous me faites penser à un
film s'appelle la vie est belle de
Franck Capra le personnage de James
notre histoire elle est
du film tu veux que je dis raconte ce
personnage de James Stewart
qui fait du bien tout le temps j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes né pour faire
du bien
et l'histoire c'est il y a un moment il
fait une connerie il décide de se
suicider
donc de disparaître et au moment où il
va pour
sauter il y a un ange gardien qui vient
qui lui dit tu es sûr que tu veux tu
veux disparaître il dit bah oui parce
que j'ai fait une connerie l'ange
gardien lui dit attendez avant de sauter
on va
on va imaginer que vous n'avez jamais
existé et vous allez voir ce que serait
devenu la ville et les gens que vous
avez fréquenté ce n’aviez pas existé
c'est moi c'est un film qui m'a
bouleversé et votre histoire elle est
incroyable quoi il y a de l'espoir
[ __ ] il y a de l'espoir la vie est
belle regardez ce film vous en supplie
montrez-le vos enfants c'est voilà je
vais lui demander de venir nous filer un
coup de main à l'UMP parce que
on a besoin des gens qui pensent beau
des gens qui ont de l'amour qui ont de
l'amour et qui pense beau merci de votre
témoignage et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu